i'm so excited for your new show i love
that for you and molly shannon was just
here yes who is so incredible in this
show i'm really glad that you two are
doing this show together yes it's thank
you that's what we all need right now in
the world thank you and maybe a little
of this too now we need a little bit of
pushing a little bit of comedy a little
bit of comfort so there's a new food
trend everybody
um and uh people right into the show and
they ask us to do a review but i'm going
to hand it over to vanessa even though
it's called drew's reviews vanessa is
going to do the review so it's drew's
reviews with vanessa
so
something got invented called the pizza
cupcake
wow wow i'm here for it i love pizza and
i love cupcakes so this feels
like a dream come true
like i don't want to i don't want to be
rude so i want to
i mean
my whole middle came out but it was
really good that's the best part to cut
your with your teeth i've got very sharp
teeth i'm going
you should put that in your baby
[Applause]
um
look vanessa thoughts okay well
i think if you had to
sum it up in one word it would be more
pizza than cupcake
i think if you know what you're getting
into you're gonna love it but if you're
but if you're expecting a cupcake you're
gonna go
well
you know that i mean i'll keep eating it
just like
i've been eating really a lot of food
today so i'm just like
well how many stars would you give this
vanessa um i would give it four stars
and here's why oh that's actually that's
pretty nice yeah i think it's pretty i
think it's pretty good it's pretty tasty
but i think it's misleading that cupcake
is in the title because i really like
even if even if you saw like just to get
okay even if you saw this you'd go oh
that's a little
like piece of bread with a pepperoni on
it you wouldn't necessarily go like oh a
cupcake you know there's going to be a
lot of cupcake fans going not my day
sorry so look how we got forks like what
if and neither of us ever were like oh
we should
maybe that's why we're not having luck
because we're not little we're not like
little ladies who go like oh
look at my plate
i took out the center oh my god everyone
i think i mean that's
you know what
i don't care you know what i want funny
i want people who put stuff out there in
the world and make all of our lives
better by putting smiles on our faces
and making us laugh
and producing material
that's gonna brighten our day
i love that for you is available to
watch today on streaming and on demand
that's right it's premiere day it's
dropped it's hot and it airs sunday
night on show time
i love you so much you too this was so
much fun
you don't need that yeah exactly i'm
like
[Applause]
this is a yeah
[Music]